[Music]
hey mom
yeah I'm pretty nervous for this
interview I spent all weekend
knowing my content so I'm ready to crush
an interview no I don't know who I'm
interviewing with I just know her name
is Tammy she's a part of the firm but
don't know much else sorry I gotta run
I'm walking into the way right now hi
Brett hey Tammy
how's it going good how are you doing oh
I'm doing good
it's a beautiful day in Palo Alto is the
weather always this nice November yes it
is it is their first time here yeah yeah
I'm from the Midwest and it's snowing
already there got it well welcome here
so I'm looking at your resumes like how
many do you think this is going well so
far show of hands how many of you think
it's too early to tell hmm let's see
what our participants think right how do
you think it's been so far as unless you
guys son
I feel think things are going pretty
well I complement to the weather talked
about the city and now I'm right across
the Saturday interesting fami what's
your opinion I've had 10 interviews
today I don't feel a special connection
with this guy he doesn't stand out Wow
did you just
did you just see how in the first 10
seconds itself there's such different
opinions of how it's gone among the two
people
first impressions in an interview are
critical where they say don't judge a
book by it's cover
that's actually what we do most of the
time first impressions are usually
formed within the first 17 seconds of
meeting someone and then they're only
reinforced with time with high
correlation research from Amy Cuddy
shows that 80% of your first impression
is based on two traits strengths how
capable and competent is this person and
warmth do I trust them thing is it
actually starts before it starts your
preparation can key you up for success
for the rest of the interview
consequently you can also put you on
your back foot so that you're always
kind of struggling to catch up so let's
take a look at a couple things we can do
to enforce good a habit building to set
you up for your best success first let's
check our online presence right if you
wouldn't mind thank you when was it you
thought you first saw Tami and she first
sight when Tammy walked down those steps
open the imaginary door and saw me say
no I think that that's maybe true but
more likely probably is that she did her
research and she saw this this is a this
is a beautiful picture of you and I
think it's take a look okay good looking
at nothing we can do to improve upon
this but please let's think a little bit
about the production value that we're
putting into this the lighting is a
little bit off you can't necessarily do
any better than this when it comes to
light the slide but there is more you
can do for a high resolution camera
let's see if we can do us put you into
the Brett you can be
you're looking good right another thing
you might want to think about is
dressing appropriately I was hoping you
might come walk me through some of your
thinking when you're not dressed
I know that Tammy's firm was business
casual so I thought it'd be good to
match business casual and be a part of
the team I can see that anyone agree
yeah I might I might suggest one one
other thing maybe consider that if
they're gonna be business casual let's
just you up just a little bit one step
above anything feel a lot more confident
you're already on stage from the second
you come in can I borrow your phone for
one though okay
I like this I'm gonna give this back to
you as soon as you are done with the
interview you can use this to call it
uber when you're done when they see you
using the phone it looks like you're not
there you're not ready let's set you up
for the best success you are here you
are present yeah okay so remember like
think about all of these things before
you go in remember that there's going to
be some habit building that happens and
we want to make sure that you're set up
for your best success because it starts
before it starts and now let's prepare
you for what it's like in a waiting room
Brett would you please act like what you
did before I have three quick tips for
you to help you to differentiate
yourself professionally in the waiting
room first try to plan to stand up
standing up based on author Peggy
Wallace gives you more power and
confidence standing up gives you more
energy because it's so much better than
if you would have watching the couch
when you're nervous in an interview your
default will be to take refuge in
thinking in that comfortable couch in
the waiting room instead of sitting
there you can look at the view out of
the window read about the art on the
wall I read about a magazine like while
you're sending seniya has one other
benefit when someone you meet comes in
sending out gives you a more fluid
transition into greeting them because
you start out as their equal rather than
from below them from a sitting position
the second tip we have for you is to
make small conversations they have you
with people in their receptionist or
there can be other candidates in the
room this helps you stretch out your
vocal cords so you can you can deliver a
more clear and resonant voice and
hopefully the admins will see that you
are a friendly person
and you're a better fit for the
company's culture convert them into your
allies the star tip we have for you is
to master the meet and greet you won't
be able to immediately have this high
energy as soon as you see someone in the
first millisecond therefore prepare the
mentality for solid first first
impression think about what you want to
do to be confident to share thisi azzam
and show that you're a polished greet
them with the open gesture a firm
handshake and a direct eye contact
breath this practice this Haley much
better isn't it so as you can see
there's three quick tips for you to
prepare in the waiting room as we said
it really starts before it starts now
let's talk about preparing Brett for the
interview Brett come on in have a seat
I have three tips for you first have
engaging conversation for your
interviewer and prepare for that do your
homework beforehand look up what they
work on where they went to school or
college what the hobbies are see if you
have any commonalities with them or
shared experiences talk about those to
build connections second let's talk
about posture friend when you sit with
your leg up against your knee and
slouching back you can make a casual
attitude at a bit of arrogance let's fix
that why don't you sit straight and try
to project confidence it's important to
maintain eye contact with your
interviewer so that they built rather it
builds trust when you look away from
your interviewer and talk they might
think you're not being genuine third
it's important to mirror the energy in
the room practice this beforehand if
your interviewer is low energy or tired
don't be too peppy if your interviewer
is high energy try to match their level
you want the interviewer to be
comfortable with your energy level and
not be awkward
so to summarize three tips do your
homework on content have engaging
conversations have a confident body
posture and mirror the energy level in
the room remember it starts before it
starts now let's see if Brett has
learned through this process
Wow I walk into the waiting room I don't
have my phone out I'm so prepared hi
Brett
hey Tammy I'm so excited to be
interviewing with you today well welcome
yeah I noticed by looking our LinkedIn
that we have a common connection
how do you know RJ Miller oh my god we
went to GSB together oh he's my neighbor
you have any good stories about him at
the time at the GSB total eye total eye
let's talk about it okay wasn't that so
much better let's ask our participants
how that felt
Tammy how did that land on you I've had
pain you know via today I won't forget
which one Bret is Bret how did that for
you I felt that went a lot better I came
in focused I wasn't distracted on my
cell phone and we made a common
connection I got my nerves down and
ready to go with it so I know as we go
through this most you think these are
just two role plays sadly monthly
half-goat in that first role play you
saw that was me
- the whole Linkedin photo I walked into
the interview wearing this but all the
other candidates had ties on I thought I
wanted to match the people I was
interviewing with I did talked about the
weather because I spent all my time
researching and preparing for my content
my interview all the other candidates we
had these crazy connections with their
interviewers and they did their homework
I walked into that we had that interview
room I was nervous
I did put my leg up it hid my nerves
I thought the portrayed confidence but
when I got the feedback after the
interview they told me that I crushed
interviews I was the most qualified
candidate for the job but I didn't get
the job because they felt I didn't take
it seriously that really hurt me because
I really focus on this interview but
like they just mentioned the first 17
seconds are super important and I think
that's what set me behind on the back
foot
fortunately the story has a happy ending
because I learn from these mistakes
didn't make this air twice got a job
that was better for me two weeks later
signed and thank you and just our hope
for you going for us when you go into
that interview do focus on dress you
know do focus on during your research on
York interviewer practice that Hochberg
before you walk in because when you can
if you do that you're gonna start off on
the right foot when you go into that
content and you will learn that I
learned the hard way that it really does
start before it's nice thank you
I want to thank you very much for
sharing that abysmal failure without
significant mistakes with that we'd love
to open up to some questions
[Music]